today I want to talk about a topic that
in my humble opinion is not talked about
frequently enough when it comes to
consulting or corporate careers in
general and this is what it takes to
become successful in these environments
as an introvert so welcome to another
coffee break here on my channel from
learning my name is Heinrich and on my
Channel I want to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career I'm a former McKinsey consultant
so this is where this video will be also
very much inspired from but also from
other roads and experiences besides that
and I want to structure this video in
three main parts first I will talk about
what it actually means to be an
introvert and whether I am one or not
second I want to talk about some typical
experiences that you will face in
Consulting based on situations that also
really happened in my career and third I
want to give you some tips some
actionable advice on what you can do to
actually survive in these environments
as an introvert so first let's start
what does it actually mean to be an
introvert and first I think there's a
very very big misunderstanding and this
is that people think about something
like social anxiety when they think
about introverts so introverts are
people who aren't really able to talk in
public to deliver speeches feel super
uncomfortable with other people right is
this really what's the case well and I
hope it's not too surprising to you that
this is actually not what at least the
psychology would say what introversion
is and the official definition that you
will find in the textbook is that for
introverts social situations are
draining their batteries so it takes
energy to be exposed to other people to
interact with other people whereas
extroverts for them it's the opposite
right so they can recharge their
batteries when they interact with other
people and based on all of this I
realized that yes I am an introvert and
while I have no problem at all with
giving public speeches I actually enjoy
it to some extent I also have no problem
at all with filming YouTube videos like
these I know know that whenever I spend
a full day together with other people
interacting with them a lot I will just
feel exhausted at the end of the day for
me social interactions like this surely
drain my battery so don't recharge my
batteries so that being said let's move
to the second part of this video why I
think that especially in Consulting you
will face quite some difficult
situations as an introvert and just to
give you some examples and I just want
to tell you some anecdotes from my life
from my past experiences I remember one
project I was actually the Project Lead
for that project so I had my team of a
handful of other Consultants who work
together with me we were all based in
the same Hotel so every single morning I
was waking up going to the hotel lobby
to pick up my breakfast and there was
actually a project which was quite tough
so the working hours were quite long I
felt quite sleep deprived most of the
days most of the weeks and as especially
in the morning I still felt quite
crushed from what happened all the days
afterwards the only thing that actually
I wanted to do was to be for myself pick
up a breakfast eat that and just try to
put myself together and prepare myself
mentally for the day but then of course
when I came down very often I saw
already some of my other colleagues of
course from the team sitting there and
getting some breakfast and I knew hey
I'm the project leader I cannot just now
sit somewhere else right and let these
people eat alone but I need to join them
sit next to them and even though this
might feel like a very small example for
me this was one of these examples where
just so also Under Pressure to spend
time together with your team colleagues
with your teammates socialize with them
even at 7am in the morning but it's
actually nothing like it would do more
than just be for yourself relax and just
enjoy your food first example second
example team room situation so this to
some extent may be changed now due to
the current post-corona situation but
still as a consultant especially in the
mbb consulting firms you will spend lots
of the time at the client side sitting
in team rooms and very often not always
but very often the client gives you a
rather small room so it's not like you
have very huge meeting rooms that you
are disposing all the time to the
contrary it would not be unusual that
you sit together with three four five
other people in a small room and you
barely have more space than something
like this right where you put your
laptop you're there then often also
clients come in maybe your partners come
in who also want a spot at the desk it's
an atmosphere where almost always
someone will be constantly on the phone
doing conference calls and video calls
in parallel where you are there trying
to work it will be very noisy I think
this environment alone for a full-blown
introvert is just pure stress it is very
difficult just to go some rates just
have time for yourself often than in
these client environments you're looking
for some rooms some empty rooms where
you maybe have a little bit of space to
potentially do a very important
confidential coil but not always there
will be while I'm sure you cannot just
go there for hours just to work right so
second situation why this might be very
stressful for an introvert third
situation social interactions Beyond
just the work during the day there are
many examples for that
a rather typical one would be that once
or twice a week usually someone senior
from your leadership someone like a
partner is flying in and spends the day
or half of the day with you and it would
not at all be unlikely that then in the
evening you would together go out for a
team dinner to spend the time together
enjoy to some extent this is very
enjoyable often you go to nice
restaurants you have very nice food and
probably more often than not this can
also be a lot of fun of course again
potentials depending on what your
personality is but here the truth is
also that again very often the days
before the weeks before you're very
little asleep you feel quite exhausted
you've quite sleep deprived and probably
there are other things that you would
likely to like to do more than I'll
spend the evening or several hours at
least together with potentially your
senior leadership your colleagues
especially if you know that once you get
back once it's 10 pm 11 pm or even late
and you get back there's still will work
to do right and I can tell you this
would not at all be an unlikely
situation and I'll try to put yourself
in the situation there's the partner who
of course is often a very social person
wants to interact with you talk to you
often there's a different projects one
project need different Associates
sitting at the desk sitting at the table
and especially when I was a junior
associate I often feel more or less
pressed that I no need to interact that
I don't need to say something talk to
the partner somehow entertain the person
and maybe to some extent that wasn't
really needed but then on the other hand
of course there's also this topic of
visibility right and how important it is
to get promoted to get to the next level
I will link somewhere above here a video
where I discussed this concept in detail
but again in a nutshell think about try
to put yourself into the shoes of a
partner maybe every half a year there's
then the evaluation season and that
partner needs to decide what associate
gets what ranking what performance
ranking which determines answer bonus
which also determines the speed of your
promotions right who is more likely to
get their promotion if the people or if
the different Associates got very
similar evaluations for instance from
the Project Lead is it the person whom
this partner vividly remembers from
regular team interaction steam dinners
like this or is the the person that in
all these interactions just sat there
didn't contribute much didn't do
anything to just somehow be remembered
really by the partner in a significant
way well I hope it's not surprising to
anyone that very likely it's the former
person who has the advantage which of
course also creates exactly the pressure
to socially interact like this and then
further depleting your batteries more
and more throughout the course of such
an already stressful day in Consulting
next example office activities so the
typical Rhythm while working in
Consulting is that from Monday to
Thursday you're really fully invested in
your client work needs to do lots of
stuff often you're also located
client-side not always but often but
then on Friday often it's a bit of a
more slower day at least traditionally
you would have had the opportunity to
move back to your home location spend
the day in the office or actually just
to start to spend the day in the home
office so now every Friday you had the
opportunity to either go home spend the
day at home potentially do a little bit
of work maybe some up and stuff or you
go to the office well why might it be a
good idea to go to the office well of
course because you meet other colleagues
you have the opportunity to network
often also different office societies
office events are taking place on the
Friday so this is the opportunity again
to expose yourself to social situations
to network in your office to get to know
more people potentially awesome Network
but the senior leaders who often also
are there on the Fridays and again now
you guess it right so for whom will it
be likely easier to decide to not just
spend the day at home and relax from
already the very stressful time you had
from Monday to Thursday the introvert or
the extrovert I trust it's clear for
whom this is the case right but again on
the other hand side missing all the
Friday's activities always surely is not
helping you in your career again we just
discussed the topic of visibility and
last but not least very much related to
that is of course also relationship with
clients especially if you are based
client side sitting at the same location
with your clients of course during the
day you will have all types of meetings
some more formal interactions with the
clients and surely this is your goal it
is your duty as a consultant to some
extent you also evaluated whether you're
able to do that or not to build
relationships at least with the most
important clients relative to know the
project topic the things that you're
working on and of course in order to do
that the best people usually are people
who are able Beyond just the very
standard formal meetings that they have
to potentially just walk by the office
pick up a cup of coffee with them maybe
just invite them for lunch spend time
with them have small talk with them and
build exactly these types of
relationships and all of this together
leads to I think the fact that often for
introverts especially in the first years
it might be a bit more challenging to
get used to this Consulting environment
to thrive and to succeed and to get the
best evaluations to be fast track
promoted and so on and so forth
so all this being said while I
acknowledge all these struggles and I
personally very much failed all these
struggles as well I do truly think that
you can succeed in Consulting
independent whether you are an introvert
or an extrovert so let me know share a
couple of tips some strategies that I
also picked up over time in order to
succeed in these roads as an introvert
indeed and first I want to talk about
just learning some of these more typical
extroverted behaviors because yes as an
introvert you can develop yourself you
can learn to also adopt some of these
Behavior patterns they might feel less
natural to you it might feel a bit more
challenging and harder to you but it is
possible there are many things now that
I can can talk about I just want to
point to one thing and this is the
so-called trust equation and I have
created a video about this as well I
will link it somewhere above here where
you can check it out it is a simple
framework of what you can do to build
trust with colleagues with clients it
discusses several actions that you can
pursue and all of them or most of them
don't really even depend on spending
lots of social time with them chatting a
lot with them so I think these
opportunities to really also succeed and
build trust with these people even with
a more introverted type of mindset
second it's not the case that you always
just need to do small talk with everyone
because typically introverts don't
really enjoy doing that typically
introverts like to have either doll more
meaningful conversations and here I
think it's a helpful mindset to adopt
that you can actually derive off the
conversation exactly in the direction
that you would like right and if you
don't want to do small talk don't do
small talk and rather move to the topics
that are more meaningful to you and in
my humble experience what I've seen
often also the other person actually
enjoys this to have this a bit more
unusual conversation with you beyond
just always talking about how the last
weekend was or maybe what your plans for
the next weekend are right and so what
might you do well there's one saying
that that sticks to my mind that I find
quite inspiring now let me know in the
comments whether you agree with this or
not but the saying says that Simple
Minds talk about other people mostly
negative
mediocre Minds talk about experiences
mostly positive and great minds talk
about ideas okay so instead of
chit-chatting about other colleagues
instead of just talking about your last
weekend what the experience was like
just try to talk about ideas so maybe
something that you read that really
inspired you that sparked some some
ideas in your mind and what the opinion
of the other person is I think this is
always a great share right talking about
books that you're reading other things
like this
if you do want to talk about experiences
well maybe don't make it about the last
weekend but for instance I crash a
question that I always liked that I find
always eliciting quite interestingly
sponsors is something like so what was
your most memorable experience while
working at this employer for the last
year what was your most memorable
experience doing this or that I think
that's a great question also to ask
maybe to a more senior colleague to a
partner what was your most memorable
experience here working in this
consulting firm always fascinating what
types of responses you get or again
instead of talking about the weekend
maybe ask something like what are you
looking forward to in the next weeks or
months what are you excited about right
this is great because then these people
also start thinking about maybe positive
emotions positive feelings thoughts that
I might have going forward a great nice
little question that I feel can also
help you to go beyond the standard small
talk next problem that of the introverts
are facing is that often as an introvert
you just set a very high bar for
yourself
in order to talk right so you feel like
in order for you to have the permission
to talk the thing that you want to say
needs to be insanely valuable and if
this what you want to say is not very
valuable then you don't really have the
right to talk and then you're often just
confused and maybe even annoyed but all
these other people around you then offer
by extroverted people who just say
things when you felt like that was
absolutely unneeded not even worth your
time right but many people do that and
in order to overcome this of course the
obvious thing is to to lower the bar a
little bit in the sense that not you
saying useless stuff all the time but
that often you're very much
underestimating the actual value of the
things that you want to contribute so
maybe you feel like a thought that you
have is obvious to everyone else which
is why you don't need to share it but
very often the truth is that this
thought that you are having is not at
all obvious to at least some people in
the room which is why many more things
very likely are worth to be shared than
you might think and one little technique
that I find quite helpful here is with
what some people call the barrier of
silence and this is that often during
the course of a meeting the longer the
meeting continues without you having
said anything the harder it will be for
you to know suddenly after the meeting
is already one hour in
to only now start talking and start
saying something for the very first time
so this barrier of silence is building
up over time the longer the meeting gets
which is why a typical recommendation is
that you should try in the very
beginning just at the start of the
meeting to say something interact with
someone just drop a couple of comments
couple of remarks even if maybe they are
not the the most valuable ones ever but
if you do this then this barrier this
perceived hurdle for you to talk again
engage again will feel much lower much
more easy to overcome than if you
wouldn't have said anything for the very
first significant part of the meeting
next tip to succeed as an introvert is
to focus more on your strengths and of
course this now Taps into some cliches
and of course introverts are also
different and not every introvert
behaves in the same way but at least
some of the strengths that are typically
associated with introverts is active
listening that maybe you don't have the
need talk all the time yourself but
actually you're a really good listener
and you can detect perceive things while
just listening to someone that maybe
someone else who is a louder or who he
or she might be louder might not be able
to do this right so active listening
build on that obviously this is a very
very crucial skill in Professional
Services second empathy
here again what many people seem to
believe is that introverts are more
empathetic because they have these
antennas for the feelings for the
emotions of other people which are easy
maybe to be overheard if you just focus
too much on just talking yourself use
that empathy is so important so crucial
for Professional Services it is a
people's business this is a relationship
business and last but not least again
maybe a cliche but many people seem to
believe that introverts are also more
analytically inclined more analytically
able again of course this is a very
valuable skill in Consulting as well so
yes maybe you won't perform to the level
as other people do in some of the other
areas where the extroverts are stronger
but then just double down on your
strengths try to really excel in the
parts where you are good at and of
course you can then also get all the
positive evaluations all the fast pack
promotions and all these things you
might fancy also not right based on such
a virtues such strengths that you can
play all right and of course last but
not least what's really important then
to you is the weekends you need to
recharge your batteries at some point
very likely for money to Thursday Monday
to Friday you won't really have the
ability to do that at some point you
should just accept that if this is you
if this is your personality probably
Saturday and Sunday it will be very
challenging for you to now also then
just do lots of social things spend lots
of time with your friends go out in the
evenings I mean if this is a great for
you if this Fields like the right thing
to do for you of course feel free to do
that but for introverts I think for many
of us for me again included the week it
was often a time where I just slept in
where I just enjoyed a slower day and
rather not engaging too much with many
other people and at some point you might
need to accept that this is just what
you need to do in order to also properly
prepare yourself for then the next
rather busy and challenging week so this
is my thoughts on introverts please let
me know in the comments is this your
experience as well I would always be
very interested also in some suggestions
that you might have on how to deal with
this my my name is Heinrich thanks to
all the members of firm learning please
leave a like if you took any value out
of this subscribe if you like this type
of content and want to see more looking
forward to the next video next week and
bye